قطعوا عنا الوقود وقطعوا عنا الميه
والكهرباء لكن ما قطعوا عنا
[موسيقى]
الانتماء نفق الب البنزين من سيارتي
واضطريت اتركها في المكان اللي انا قويت
له في البريج واضطريت
اشتري دراجه هوائيه وبروح تقريبا 15 م
رايح جاي على غزه على مركز الامراض
المزمنه حتى اتابع المرضى تبعتي وانت عارف
الفتره الاخيره
هذه فتره الحرب معظم الحالات اوت للمدارس
مدارس الاواء في الاونروا مشكورين حاولوا
يساعدوا في الجانب هذا لكن معظم الحالات
تركت علاجاتها جوا
ال تحت الركام وتحت الردن واضطرينا ان نلف
عليهم في المدارس ونشوفهم ونوفر لهم
العلاجات تبعت الامراض المزمنه خاصه للي
عندهم ضغط وسكر لانهم اكثر عرضه للوفاه
وخاصه ما فيش اكسبي او فش تواصل مع فيش
مواصلات فيش وقود اللي يوصلوا المستشفيات
اذا طورت الحاله وخش في غيبوبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
او ومن بعض الصعوبات احيانا بتكون حكايه
انه في الشارع نفسه بكون في قصف والشارع
بكون مقلوب من راسا على عقب فبضطر بدل ما
امشي على البسكليت احمل البسكليت على
اكتافي وامشي فتره لغايه ما اتجاوز الردم
والدمار اللي حاصل حتى اخش في الشارع
المعبد اللي اقدر اوصل
[موسيقى]
فيه
وبعض الاحيان بعمل زيارات بيتيه لبعض
الحالات الجرحى اللي ما بتقدر توصل واللي
بكون معنا كونتاكت للاتصال مع وبتوقع يعني
فيش طبيب في غزه الا
عنده القدره انه يعمل هيك واكثر
[موسيقى]
كمان m